good evening ladies and gentlemen
members of
and officers of the council there's no
members of the public welcome to this
meeting of the standards committee
if the firearm alarm is activated please
vacate
the offices via the stirs either through
the security door to the left
of the chairman or opposite the lifts in
the foyer please do not use the lifts
please assemble the holy square on the
green
officers will assist you and advise you
when it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber
does anyone intend filming the meeting
good
there's no members of the public here
please note this meeting is being live
stream for members of the public except
for any item of business where exempt or
confidential information
is considered following the exclusion of
the present public from the meeting
the meeting is also being recorded and
will broadcast on the council's youtube
channel
but everyone please ensure their mobile
phones are turned to silent and they are
not
made not used to make or receive calls
in the chamber during this meeting
i have counsellor garner to speak on
item 5 and councillors garner bailey to
speak on item six is that correct
okay
apologies have been received from
councillor cup and the council's
independent person dennis james are
there any other apologies
good
i move that the minutes of the meeting
yelled on the 25th of november 2021 be
improved and signed as a correct record
could i have a seconder please
as unless anyone objects to the minutes
i'll take them as agreed
thank you
are there any declarations of interest
item gender 4 is revision to delegations
mr use committee services manager would
you like to introduce a report please
thank you chairman
yes so this report is regarding uh
recommending uh amending this council
scheme of delegations to authorize the
chief executive to declare vacancies in
office under section 86 local government
act 1972
what i would start with is um that
uh this is regarding uh when a counselor
ceases to be a counselor through
immediate disqualification so either
through failure to attend meetings
um
being disqualified through uh committing
a crime and being sentenced to uh prison
centers of more than three months what i
would start with is uh it doesn't relate
to resignation and neither does it
relate to death
so it's only in a very
specific set of circumstances
um
what we
are suggesting is that the chief
executive is allowed to um declare
vacancies
whereas at the moment that is currently
reserved to full council
so you can as we've recently witnessed
have a rather odd situation whereby a
councillor can
become
disqualified from being a councillor
however they would remain a councillor
up until the point that full council
[Music]
agrees to make the declaration a vacancy
even though that person should
technically be
be disqualified
now that isn't particularly helpful for
the member concerned and it's neither is
it very helpful for the council
and in many other councils across the
country uh this is delegated to the
chief executive so that once
the discussions and and backroom
uh discussions about
the validity of whether that person has
been disqualified
have been concluded a declaration of
vacancy can then be immediately
made and that then allows the council to
get on with the process of um
organizing a uh a by-election
uh i think that was
all i wanted to say on that i don't
think um
yeah no any questions happy to answer
them
so
counseling crow browns in front of your
name okay so counselor
duckworth
um
yeah it seems to me that the um
the recommendation
doesn't really make it clear in what
circumstances this can happen as you
said it could only happen
in the circumstances if somebody hadn't
attended meetings
or
if they um
had a prison sentence of more than three
months
so i'd be happy to vote for it if it
actually says in the recommendation
i'd happy to say you know we can
recommend this to ca at least get
council i believe
um
if it said that because it seems like
there could be other circumstances
um the recommendation effectively says
that by saying declarations in off by
declaring vacancies in office under
section 86 of local government act 72
so there's the circumstances where she's
allowed to do that are outlined within
the the local section 86 so she wouldn't
be able to do any other declarations of
interest sorry declarations of vacancy
for anything else
and also you don't need to do a
declaration of inter a vacancy for a
death or a resignation so it would just
be in the second
i mean there are other circumstances and
deaths and resignations and the ones
that
you know
sometimes it can be complicated or some
sometimes there can be other reasons why
somebody
may need to be disqualified but it could
be disputed
um so
does the the section 86 only refer to
those two
that you mentioned
what would happen if there was
you know somebody
i don't know a conflict of interest or
something like that that was disputed
the only other one that springs to mind
is where somebody's employed by the
council it's the only other way that you
can be disqualified from being a
councillor
uh so there's the only as far as i'm
aware that's the only three reasons
isn't it that cover the disqualification
element of it which is you're employed
by the councils who immediately cease
um
uh you're sentenced uh to prison over
three months or you're um
you don't attend for six months
that's the
the only three reasons why you can be
disqualified
and then anything else that's not a
disqualification
you don't need because the only other
way you would do it is death or
resignation
so
yeah
okay how would the backroom
discussions take place
he said they'd be sort of decided
um yeah perhaps if i could just step in
here so
all we're saying is that um
delegating the authority to the chief
executive
makes it a speedier process than having
to wait for the next council meeting
because the legislation says that once
somebody hasn't attended
meetings for six months
the council shall declare the vacancy
and that's the point
um
the declaration is the point when the
when the um vacancy arises and it says
you shall the council shall declare the
vacancy fourth width and the only
meaning of fourth width is as soon as
possible so if you haven't got another
council meeting scheduled for another
two months you've either got to hold an
extraordinary council meeting and then
there's the usual notice requirements
and getting everybody together for that
so inevitably there's some delay but if
we delegated it to the chief executive
it doesn't mean that
if there's an allegation that somebody
hasn't attended for six months
madeleine's going to instantly issue
that declaration
she would obviously talk to a person's
group leader the person themselves
probably the other group leaders there
would be a process of discussion about
it and the other thing to remember is
if the council has delegated it to
um the chief executive there's no reason
why the council itself still can't
exercise that power so if there were any
doubt it could be that it went to full
council for decision but this just means
that there is a speedier resolution
like the unfortunate situation we had
recently it caused a lot of
angst
no doubt for the member i'm sure i know
for the member concerned and a lot of
pain generally and actually if we'd had
a speedier process once we'd clarified
the situation and it was quite obvious
actually once we looked at the the
attendance stats
and the legislation is quite clear in
its wording because it says six months
from the date of the last attendance so
it's absolutely clear
and nick and i looked into into it in
great detail so it just allows once once
you've
been through that bit of a debate about
about the timing and
everybody's sure of what's going on it
just allows it to happen more quickly it
doesn't say that we're going to go off
and have all these rogue
rogue chief executive decisions left
right and center that that just wouldn't
happen i mean she you know she just
wouldn't do that but it just means the
mechanics of it are easier more easily
dealt with really
if that helps so
so yeah no i understand that you know in
that particular case obviously it would
have been a lot easier
um
so this
the legislation only allows for those
three circumstances then
for disqualification
well as long as yes so um as long as
that's minuted that i've
said that's what
i think i'm
i'm recommending
and that's fine
can i just come and clarify something so
the problem is with um these various
circumstances when somebody ceases to be
a counsellor it's about the date of the
vacancy so if somebody resigns or if
somebody unfortunately passes away
the vacancy instantly arises so there's
no need for a declaration so it just
sort of happens it's those issues where
there has to be a date of a declaration
like this circumstance here so it means
you're in this period of limbo because
the vacancy hasn't arisen even though
they are disqualified by operation of
law
so it just creates that sort of awkward
limbo situation of of a few weeks
because the legislation says the vacancy
only arises on the declaration
whereas if somebody resigns it arises on
the on the point of notification of the
resignation automatically
yeah that's all understood as providing
it's just in those three circumstances
then
it's fine
i think it's a case of from the outside
looking in speeding up the process
council garner you wish to comment
well actually my um correction earlier
was incorrect so i apologize for that i
got my numbering wrong on my notes
i'm i'm here to speak on items five and
six as correctly stated
thank you for your honesty it counts as
scoby
thank you can i just um
ask out of interest what what does
democratic services um do when somebody
is getting close to their um
um
six months do do they inform the the
chief whip of the party do they talk to
the person it's just i remember uh
many years ago a lady from
the villages whose name escapes me
um she had a stroke
and she wasn't able to attend council
meetings for more than six months and we
actually extended
uh
her her term of attendance
pickering her name was pickering audrey
pickering
yeah we don't um it's not democratic
services responsibility to tell members
when they're within the six months
however that being said
if members do let us know if there's an
ongoing health issue for example then um
we can uh at the request of uh either
the group leader
or full council
put a
a report to full council and full
council can grant that individual an
extension of time beyond the six months
but it's very clear within the
legislation that that
the debt the the decision to um extend
the six months must be made within
the six month period it can't be they've
come to the end of six months and then
say well i'm not very well
can i have some more time
it's very clear that
if you tell us within six months of the
last time you went to a meeting that
you're not very well we can put a
process in in
um
in train that allows for an extension
obviously if we don't know then
we we can't do anything about that so in
in this recent event the person hadn't
informed you that she'd had a stroke
no
thank you
yeah thank you i think it's quite
straightforward and i'd like to propose
that we accept the recommendations
thank you council fellows
do you wish me to read the
recommendation or are you all ready to
know you're happy with it
could i have a second of them please
counselor pro brown
right going on to item agenda 5.
sorry you want to vote i do apologize
i'm not used to him sitting on my
shoulder
could we take a vote on that please
those in favor
those against
us
right item agenda
five
the recommendations in this report were
considered by the constitutional review
working party on the 23rd of february
2022 after discussion on the matter they
agreed to put to the standards committee
that crwp recommends to the standards
committee that can't the council make
amendments to council procedural 2.4
regarding the leaders report as outlined
in annex one to the report
i have counselor garner who wishes to
speak under council rule procedure 20.1
thank you yes i am prepared for this
item thank you
yeah i just want to raise a couple of
points
related to the proposed changes to the
leaders report section
firstly and speaking as
currently the leader of one of the
groups
i believe it is helpful for leaders of
other groups to be able to submit
questions few days before to enable the
leader to prepare answers in advance of
the meeting
this is a welcome suggestion
i cannot however
accept that any further questions which
may arise should be ruled out of order
i can envisage a scenario where another
question not thought of earlier may
occur during exchanges
during the with other leaders
are we really saying that these should
be ruled out of order
if an answer can't be provided on the
night i'm sure we are prepared to wait a
couple of days for them
i'm concerned
additionally because we are in danger of
making our council meetings so sterile
and scripted that we might as well
cancel the meeting altogether and just
issue a report and i'm sure none of us
want that
thank you
thank you council ghana i think mr
hughes would like to come back on that
i'll outline the report
i'm sure i'll come back on that
particular point but i can outline the
report for you
so the leader of the council has asked
democratic services to propose a number
of amendments to
the council procedure rules regarding
the leaders report
and as outlined by council ghana that is
to ask group leaders of opposition
groups to submit their questions uh on
the leaders report to the leader in
advance of the meeting and that would
then allow the leader more time to
provide a comprehensive answer at the
meeting itself
uh in order to do this the requirements
uh to
the constitution that would need to
change
uh would make it so that
uh the leader of the council would make
uh their report uh available in writing
a week uh at least a week uh in advance
of the meeting currently that happens on
the saturday before the meeting
then the leader of any political group
must then provide the leader and
chairman with any questions that they
intend to ask
as part of their sponsored leaders
speech by closing business on the
tuesday prior to the meeting
and as as was referred to any questions
on the leads of the speech that were not
submitted in advance by the political
group leaders would be then ruled as
inadmissible by the chairman
um this was again considered uh as the
chairman has mentioned at the last
meeting of the constitutionally working
party uh one thing that was mentioned at
the last meeting was that
if
there was a situation whereby some
unexpected news event had happened
between
the point at which the uh
leaders report had been issued by the
leader
and uh the actual council meeting if the
uh chairman was so agreed to let the
leader add
uh a piece of detail to the leads report
then
opposition group leaders would also then
get the opportunity to
um
add in um a further question based on
the added
content by the leader
although that's not added into the uh
rules here uh because that is actually
in the gift of the chairman so it's it's
it's his prerogative to do that um
so that is the proposed uh change so
happy to answer any questions
counselor bayford
thank you chair yeah i mean in view of
the fact that leaders will have seen
the report
um
except in the situation that nix has
already
described where something new occurs i
can't see why there would be any
questions
that they hadn't already thought about
so i
i would have thought
this was fairly straightforward
accepting the situation
um
described and in which case i feel sure
that if it was something quite important
the chairman would be very happy to
accept questions
so i'm very happy to support this
that that was discussed and
as you rightly say if it was important
enough it would be included and the
chair would no doubt allow questions
council crittenden
thank you um
i have to say that some of what i'm
about to say is
going to support um what counselor ghana
has already said because i was really
quite surprised to see this amendment
this proposal come
um
be given that uh the leader came into
the role with a strong message about
improving the functioning of the council
i'm not sure this does that and i'm
surprised that the constitutional review
working party also agreed with it
i understand the reasoning about coming
with more comprehensive answers
but if we're going to make changes to
the constitution we must not look only
at the impact of those changes now but
what those changes are going to do in
future administrations and future
generations
and so my my primary objection to the
proposed change is that it's effectively
going to contribute to the silencing of
the political voice and discourse of the
council and give more power and
responsibility to the officers who are
the ones who will inevitably be
providing the answers to the questions
my secondary question was i think you've
actually answered my um which was that
it won't allow for the raising of any
emergency issues although um the fact
that you said that it will be
constrained to only if the leader
mentions it first i'm not sure that
that helps
i'm sure there'll be some leaders who
will appreciate being able to
use officers
taking responsibility for answering the
questions
but is that what we want to encourage
isn't it our responsibility to our
electorates to keep this chamber as
democratic as possible to promote
openness and freedom of speech instead
instead of to counsel a garden at ghana
sterilizing it yet more
i also have to ask if now is actually an
appropriate time to be making this kind
of change to the constitution when we're
still in the middle of the significant
piece of work by the independent
monitoring officer to bring about
improvements in the overall functioning
of the council
and an
intervention which councillor ashby
herself welcomed and i would have
thought that this proposed amendment
cuts across that piece of work and i
would like to propose that we refer this
proposal to the end independent
monitoring officer for further advice or
action
thank you
i'll second that
first time you heard it as well
yeah so um so i think that's a valid
amendment that's been proposed and
seconded so um do we want to talk about
that amendment or do we want to take a
vote on that amendment
i believe the amendment is that we refer
the whole of these uh this i item to
quentin to have a look at and comment on
is that correct so the amen the all the
amendments on the item on the leaders
report
so in a nutshell agenda item five you
want referring to
the independent monitoring officer and
i've got a proposal which was council
crittenden and councillor scobee was a
seconder
all those in favor
yeah sorry however we deal with it
whether we deal with it an amendment or
simply a proposal i just do have a
comment in that um
so mr baker has been enormously helpful
and is you know working away feverishly
he may say i don't know but he may say
this is outside of his remit uh but we
can
you know if that's what you would like
to do then of course i can ask him if he
would
like to comment on it that's not a
problem
can can i just say
scoby wishes to say something
um yes
the word sterile
that that that shouts at me as what
we're doing to uh the democracy of the
council
i've got used to over the last few years
the cut and thrust of um
the leaders sparring with each other and
it actually makes for more interesting
political
debate
it seems that we're we're now getting a
leader's report which is a week old
and uh before
i think the leader
before covid the leader occasionally
released um their report to other group
leaders perhaps on the day
or the day before we're now giving seven
days and in that time
issues can change new issues can come up
and i i i think it will be
anti-democratic
thank you
mr lorenzo i believe you want to say
something
purely speaking as an independent member
um i would prefer to see the cut and
thrust remain within the council chamber
this does actually sultify to it to an
extent and i would regret it if it
if it were approved
cancer crittenden
did you wish to say something
the only thing is i responding to
estelle was that the wording was for
further advice or action um
as appropriate as the independent
monitoring officer
decides
council bayford
thank you chair i disagree i feel that
questions
to the leader should be genuine
questions based on the report nothing
more i cannot see why anyone would be
unwilling to declare
their questions in advance we've already
covered the situation where something
new arises so i cannot see any reason
for it to go to an appointment monitor
officer
thank you
so counselor dexter
thank you mr chair um can we just be
clear on this
whatever we decide has he got to be
ratified at full council
whatever we decide this evening
um has it got to be ratified at full
council okay thank you
sorry the next full council is on the
31st of march so we don't have long to
wait so we can whatever you decide if
you decide on any amendments we can get
it to that meeting on the 31st of march
so we've now got the proposal and the
seconder
can i take a vote
those in favor
those against
can we now go to item agenda
six
and i think council garner wants to
speak on this also
or have you got your sons wrong no my
sons are correct you we're all correct
on this one thank you very much
yes
thank you
one of the constitutional amendments
which recently improved things
was when the length of questions asked
by members was increased
from 50 to 150 letters
it gave us a chance to outline more of
the context of the question for the
benefit of our residents who i'm sure we
all agree are the people we need to be
working harder to engage with the whole
process of the council meeting
i see this proposed change as a
retrograde step to that
i think it's
i think it's important to encourage
questions on operational matters in the
public form of our council meetings so
that our residents have an opportunity
to hear the answers after all it's
usually because of correspondence
receiving residents that we ask these
questions in the first place
i'm also disappointed that you seem to
be taking this opportunity to discourage
members who do ask questions
from doing so by giving the chair more
power
to hinder their opportunity to ask
follow-up questions
cabinet members often have long answers
to readout prepared by officers and the
member who asked a question in the first
place
might need a few moments to gather their
thoughts before asking their follow-up
question
i think the chair should be there to
support all members
by encouraging participation rather than
closing it down
i would rather see a change to the
constitution along those lines
than this one encouraging this or future
chairs to close down members of the
council whose main motive after all
is to attempt to participate in the
democratic process on behalf of their
residents
please can you reconsider this proposed
change and i would just like to add to
that that these comments are around the
constitution around
previous one around the leader role not
not personal it's around the role of the
leader and this is around the role of
the members and the role of the chair
whoever it may be
thank you
thank you councillor ghana i believe
councillor bailey you wish to say
something
yes thank you good evening i think
cancer gone has been looking at my notes
i'm very similar
um so yes i i did follow the discussion
last week online uh with slight concern
um i do understand you know the the
concern that
run of the meal operational questions
could could be asked directly but that's
not always the case um
we don't always get a response um and
and in general i think i think
most of the questions generally are um
you know of import to our residents
um so asking questions at full council
is one of the very few occasions that
back bench counsellors like myself have
to air the concerns and to bring issues
that affect their awards to the fore
and i would also plug um
the point that independent counselors
like me do not have the same channels of
communication that members of the party
have and so this is a further
opportunity to seek information and
clarification on matters
um i'd like to think that all in any
questions put forward by members is for
the ultimate interest and benefit of
their community and not as was mentioned
at a previous meeting for grandstanding
or political posturing
and with all respect to the leader and
her invitation to knock on her door many
of the questions are asked of interest
to the wider community and a full and
transparent response to an important
question deserves to be heard in my
opinion and minuted
the second point about supplementary
questions
um yeah of course i totally agree
supplementary questions should arise
from and be connected to the original
question
but as council garner said there's often
a lot to absorb in the response to the
substance substantive question and
sometimes there's a moments reflection
needed to formulate a further
unrehearsed question in response
it certainly doesn't help this thinking
process when the chair is constantly
trying to chive you up
a supplementary question also needs to
be given a little context so i
my suggestion would be that maybe a
maximum of two uninterrupted minutes
were given to um asked to ask a
supplementary question
thank you
thank you council bailey the report was
considered by the constitutional review
working party on the 23rd of february
and after the discussion on the matter
they agreed to put to the standards
committee that council procedure rule
14.6
there should be no restriction on
questions relating to straightforward
operational matters at this time
this will be reviewed in six months
following the implementation of the
members portal
that the bullet point related to a
matter which has already been raised as
a standards complaint against a member
and which has not yet been concluded
through the code of conduct procedures
be added to the list of reasons that
would invalidate a question
and council procedure rule 14.8
that the following sentence be added to
the end of the existing paragraph
the question must be a question
and not a statement
arise directly out of the response
and i'll ask estelle to introduce
the report please
sorry
thank you chair
i mean i think the chair has summed it
up really but i'll just go through and
give you a bit of a
a bit more of an explanation about the
thinking of crwp so
the matter arose because of some
concerns about some of the recent
questions that have been asked at
council
and so um
crwp were asked to look at the
procedural 14 which is members questions
of either the leader or chairs of
committees at council
and i think
the concerns have been raised because
there had been some recent questions
that council
either related to either related to
straightforward operational matters that
it was felt could be better directed at
officers
or questions about matters over which
the council has little control for
example government guidance and
government planning policy
um even though the questions were
couched in
district council terms
so
crwp were asked to consider whether they
wish to propose any amendments to the
rules or members questions
but in in their discussion and we did
have quite a lot of discussion about it
the group were very conscious of the
important role that members questions
play in holding the administration to
account
and then promoting democracy which is
obviously what you've said counselor
bailey
so
they had quite a big discussion about
this issue of operational questions and
whether we or questions on operational
matters and whether as one of the
criteria for refusing questions we say
that um if a question is a
straightforward operational matter it it
won't be allowed
um then
so that you will see on the report that
there is a a suggested amendment in red
to the re to the grounds for refusal
relating to operational questions
but then crwp talked about the fact that
we've got this app in development
which you should all be aware about i
hope
excuse me which is hopefully
yeah well i think we're all terrified by
it so um included um
which should improve this communication
channel between members and officers and
hopefully
we'll encourage those of us who are
sometimes a bit slow to reply to
actually deal with things and get back
to you and and hopefully it will just
improve that process
so what crwp wanted to do was to not put
in the operational questions will not be
answered as it were double negative
wait until the app is in is has been
rolled out and see how it's working and
then revisit the question again so for
the time being
we're not putting in anything about you
can't ask operational questions so
so obviously that you know that will
that's the proposal from crwp
and then um
[Music]
the second proposal
sorry excuse me was that if we've got a
live code of conduct complaint or
investigation against a member and a
question is asked directly relating to
that same issue that the question
shouldn't be allowed and that makes a
lot of sense because when we have code
of conduct matters going on we do stress
to the person raising the complaint and
the person complained about the member
complained about that it's a
confidential issue and we ask people not
to we ask them not to comment publicly
on it so it seems rather unfair to the
member complained about that if we're
saying that in the process
that other members should be allowed to
ask questions directly related to that
matter
and that arose recently so we so crwp
thought that that was quite a sensible
amendment to make to the rules on
members questions
and the final amendment which is
self-evident because you've talked about
it and the chairs mentioned it relates
to supplementary questions and this just
arose
out of the slight frustration at um
supplementary questions leading were not
really being questions but being more of
a
fairly long-winded statement on some
occasions
and so it was um
suggested that we put in this this
emphasis of the wording that the
follow-up question must be a question
not a statement or must arise directly
sorry excuse me asked the response
um to the first question so so that
those are the amendments um proposed by
crwp but it's entirely within your gift
to accept them reject them or to make
some additional or different amendments
in fact
happy to take questions thank you
thank you estelle can i just say it was
a long discussion what we were concerned
about especially this bit about the
supplementary question
that some members were actually speaking
for two minutes or so
and making a statement in rather than
asking the question and that's why we've
tried to get it into the system to make
it
a lot fairer for people who want to ask
questions back to whoever's been spoken
to at the time council clinton
thank you i can assure you i have no um
motions at the end of this um but just
to comment on it and i also can assure
you that i have not liaised with
councillors ghana or bailey before
coming tonight um i do understand uh the
whole thing about um not asking
straightforward operational matter
questions um but i think as the has come
out of the uh constitutional review
working party comments we have had
difficulties in getting answers and i
think that that is partly why that's
happened
um
the other thing that uh
has also happened um
is that
when we do get answers
those answers aren't always very helpful
so i might ask when is something likely
to happen no i'm i'm saying likely not i
don't want it in stone i don't want and
i'm not going to hold your toes to the
fire if you tell me it's going to happen
on the 10th of march i'm not going to
expect that
roughly
but
very often you get the answer back
it's on the to-do list
it'll happen in due course
that's non-information it's meaningless
if i say how long is it likely to take
before something happens and you and the
officer comes back and says it's on the
action list
that's i've got i've still got no idea
and so those kind of communications can
take months
before we get to
something resembling an answer and so
the thing that i want to raise is that
the constitutional review working
party's recommendation i quite i'm happy
with to defer this for until the hub has
got going i've seen the hub i was
horrified at my first glance but they
were it was very very much the first
draft and they took on board all of our
suggestions and i'm looking forward to
actually seeing it how it works
um but i would like not just a
quantitative quantitative
analysis of how well the hub works but a
qualitative
analysis as well
so are we not are we are we getting
replies but are those replies any more
meaningful
than they have been does that all make
sense i hope it does
um
i think the second amendment on here
fine
that's you know there's no query on that
um
but i did also want to copy uh comment
on the the third amendment in this
section
um
it it just seems that our chair was in
the early days perhaps a little too
lenient
um with some of us um
and
we're now reaping
the rewards of that he has become rather
overly robust as was the wording of the
original suggestion in the last meeting
or so
um and i think that there is a hopefully
that we will be able to find somewhere
in between
um
but like counselor bailey i actually do
think that
if you just drop in a question without
at least a sentence or two to say
why
that answer that you've just heard
um
needs a supplementary question
then i think that uh it then is harmful
again to the democratic process and and
i felt a lot of what we've talked about
tonight we talked about how things have
become sterile and sometimes you know
the just the
the fun
the banter has gone
um
and i and i'm just a little bit
concerned that
this one this last one is yet another
slicing away of that
um
so
i would like it to include
with councillor bailey um just let us
have let's just say a sentence or two at
the beginning because the last time last
couple of times it's been got to go
straight into the question and
you can't you just you can't do that
always and sometimes it doesn't make
sense if you do that thank you
i can't speak on behalf of obviously the
officers on who will be responsible for
the quality assurance of the members
portal and i don't think this it would
be in the remit of this committee to
deal with the quality issues
i think i might be right mr use
we can certainly take that on board
but yeah it's not matter for this
committee but we can certainly
absolutely mention that too yeah
if not if you could it's i'm because i
know that the hub or the portal is um
one of the things that is going to come
out of it is a quantitative measurement
and that is what the hub can can do and
it will be good at that but at the same
time at the end of that it's all very
well to say yes you're getting answers
but can you actually come to us and say
are those answers worth anything are
they better than they were before um
because they might be
that you know that might be that might
be the case because you know once it's
more controlled and senior officers are
less under pressured by reams of emails
because i do feel sorry for senior
officers who are
un getting buried under reams of emails
but that's why we
we want that as well and there's a
backbencher frankly
communication's the worst thing on the
planet here
yes
thank you
is there anybody else wants to make any
comments
thank you chair um yes i'm happy uh
particularly with the hub
coming into effect on first one
second on the supplementary questions i
think this is absolutely right
the questions must be related to the
first one it's unfair on the person
answering the question it's not supposed
to be to catch them out it's supposed to
be
helpful
and to clarify the answer that's given
questions time is limited in council
meetings therefore
longer somebody goes on introducing
something and a lot of background that
we probably already know about it means
perhaps that someone else can't have a
question i think it's important that we
we do stick to actual questions
related clearly to the first
thank you
thank you and just give me one minute
find a quick discussion without any
statements
what we intend to do if we break down
what the recommendation has been put
forward to tonight's meeting into three
sections and we will seek proposers and
seconders and take a vote on each one
and i think
our old members agreed with that
thank you
so the fir the first point
is council procedural 14.6 bullet point
one
there should be no restriction on
questions relating to straightforward
operational matters at this time
this would be reviewed in six months
following the implementation of the
member's portal
could i have a proposal
counselor bayford and the secondary
counselor christendom
all those in favor
thank you
i need to talk to people
[Laughter]
being a dinosaur i would second that
bullet point two
that the bullet point related to the
matter which has already been raised as
standards complaint against a member and
which has not yet been concluded through
the code of conduct procedures
be added to the list of reasons that
would invalidate a question could i ever
propose
council of fellows those in favor
thank you
until we get to this one
right
council procedure rule 14.8
that the following sentence be added to
the end of the existing paragraph
the question must be a question
and not a statement
and rise directly out of the response
could i have a proposal
sorry um before that what i've somewhere
in here it says oh next bit it says
members are asked to consider whether to
accept the original suggested amendments
or to accept recommendations and or make
additional suggestions
um can we make an additional suggestion
to that one that um
uh priest pre-question should know what
be no more than a sentence or a brief
sentence or two
as councillor bailly and i can i suggest
i think that will be a proposal once
we've voted on this third point
because i've got a feeling that might be
yeah that's affected
so it's whatever you whatever counselor
crittenden have you got a wording that
you wish to add into that proposal
i wasn't prepared for that
um i'd like you had a week's
notification
in um
introduc an introduction to the question
should be no more than
uh
should be only very brief
i think
or should be brief
but it's controlled by the two minutes
well it is partly so if you use the two
minutes up in your preamble you don't
get the question
right so
i think what we're saying is
yeah
yeah sorry yeah
yeah so sorry can i just clarify this at
the moment the proposal is or when it's
proposed sorry the recommendation is
that we add the following sentence the
question must be this is to supplemental
questions the question must be a
question and not a statement and rise
directly out of the response and i
believe councillor crittenden what you
want to add to that sentence is
an introduction to the question should
be very brief
is that correct
so that's that's an amendment
that's an amendment that you're
proposing
which we need a second before
council scovie is the seconder for the
amendment
should we say an introduction to the
question can be given but it should be
very brief
yeah yeah you can say that yeah yes i
think council clinton would you agree to
that
that
what was it what was it
um
an introduction
to the question can be given
it should be very brief
right
so that is an amendment
so first of all do we need to get
get rid of the first proposal no no no
no okay
also if the question is directly related
to the first question which it should be
why would there need be need for any
introduction
thank you
counselor crittenden because you might
need to explain why the
answer was inadequate
thank you
does there anybody else wish to make any
comment
so can we now then have a proposal for
the amendment please
we've already got one there
can we now
take a vote on how we agreed to put that
forward
all those in favor
of the amendment
okay those against
the amendment
the amendment is lost
we're back now to the original proposal
and i need this proposal and a second
before it and i'll just
go over it so we know what we're saying
that the following sentence be added at
the end of the existing paragraph
the question must be a question
and not a statement and rise directly
out of the response could i have a
proposal please counsel fellows
council bayford second
all those in agreement
those against
that that proposal is carried
so if we can now move on to item agenda
seven
which is
the lead
my report
i think you've all
seen it and read it
i am happy to take any questions has
anybody got anything to raise before it
goes to full council on the 31st of
march
could i please have a proposal and a
seconder to put my report to the full
council
council crow bound and councillor scoby
agenda item 8
standards complaint statistics
sorry
are we all in agreement with the last
proposal
statements and questions time
does anyone have any questions regarding
the current standards complaint
statistics
if not would members please note them
does anybody wish to make any comment